[موسيقى]
هناك ادراك في بريطانيا انه اذا ما استمرت
روسيا من دون مقاومه واذا لم نقدم الدعم
لاوكرانيا فالمساله بالتالي لن تتوقف في
اوكرانيا والدول التاليه ستكون هي دول
البلطيق لذلك علينا ان نتخذ موقفا قويا
لدعم الحكومه الديمقراطيه في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
كعددا قليلا من الدول التي تحافظ على
مستويات عاليه من المخزون العسكري
والذخائر كما ان مخزون الذخائر يبقى من
دون استخدام في الدوله التي لا تخوض صراعا
عسكريا ولا توفر ذخيره الى دوله داخله في
صراع عسكري وعندما تنفذ مده صلاحيه
الذخائر علينا التخلص منها وهذه العمليه
تكلف اموالا طائله لذلك نادرا ما نجد دوله
تحافظ على مستويات عاليه من الذخيره
[موسيقى]
وبعد اندلاع الصراع في اوكرانيا وجدت عده
دول نفسها في الموقف نفسه وليس فقط
بريطانيا بل امريكا ايضا التي تعيش نفس
الظروف فيما يخص مخزونها العسكري خاصه
الصواريخ
[موسيقى]
خطوات في امريكا وبريطانيا حاليا لتعزيز
سلاسل الامداد التي توفر هذه الاسلحه
لاننا لا نتحدث عن شركه واحده فقط بل
مقاول رئيسي واحد وعده شركات تزود
المكونات وقد بدات الحكومات الان في
مراجعه سلاسل الامداد لتعمل على تقويتها
[موسيقى]